the hardest respect to earn is one's own
over the years my wife and i created
acquisition.com which portfolio of
companies does about 85 million a year
and i have nothing to sell you i get
questions all the time in terms of like
how do you create these businesses how
do you sell stuff how do you live your
life all of those kinds of things and i
was talking to a good friend who'd come
back
into my life briefly we actually started
at the same time together there was a
there was a period of time that he did
significantly better than me just from a
financial perspective and then i ended
up passing him and we met back up a few
years later and he was a little bit down
and the conversation that we had was
really enlightening for me and the
conversations we've had since and so i
wanted to share that with you the main
purpose for this video as i'm getting to
it is to underline how do you actually
do the stuff that creates the wealth the
empire the status all that stuff and i
think that this is where people get
really tripped up the reason i say that
is there's kind of three elements to the
the goal right so you have the external
result that you're looking for which
might be make more money get a six-pack
whatever you've got the processes
behaviors activity that result in that
goal right being achieved which would be
like doing the work the third aspect is
being the type of person who does those
things so basically identifying
with those types of behaviors or being
the type of person who does those types
of activities which then creates the
reward right i think james clear talks
about this in his book atomic habits but
there's a lot of behavioral
psychologists who've touched on this
point and you probably have heard be do
have at some point in your personal
development journey and if you haven't
welcome to the game and so one of the
things and this is what i wanted to give
to you in this in this video is a
keystone habit that has served me very
well and it's only been in retrospect
explaining it to someone else that i
kind of had more clarity on it which is
why i'm sharing it with you when i have
something that i want that i do not have
so i have a desire which means i've made
a contract with myself to be unhappy
until i get what i want right and so i
have this thing that i want externally
and i think i've had enough experience
with this to know that simply writing
down the goal means nothing and so i
think this is contrary to common belief
or practice which is like people write
down their goals are more likely to
succeed sure i mean having a direction
is more likely to achieve them than not
having a direction so i'm not going to
disagree with that but here's an
interesting statement that um may hit
you which is that winners and losers
have the same goals right everybody
olympics has the same goal everybody
who's in business has the same goal
right they want to increase how much
money they're making you sell more
products get more customers etc so the
goals are actually not that unique and
so the fact that we're writing them down
sure it's a first step because we have
to have a direction in terms of what are
we trying to accomplish sure but i think
that what you'll see that is different
because if you look at two people with
the same goals and one person achieves
them the other person hasn't then it
can't be having the goal that is the
main driver of success right right and
so then you get you know you dive a step
underneath that and you look at what are
the behaviors that created that goal and
now we get much closer to the things
that are actually driving the progress
what gets more interesting at least to
me is if we know the activities that are
going to generate the result we want so
maybe it's we want to get more customers
which means we need to advertise more
and i use advertised by the definition
of what the word actually means which is
to make known and so if we do activities
that make our products and services
known like doing more private
communications which would be one-on-one
reach outs 101 cold calls 101 dms 101
emails etc prospecting or one-to-many so
public communication which should be uh
you know broadcasting across different
platforms for media right so you have
radio you could have an email list you
could have um actually that would be an
example of a high version of scale of
the original so i apologize there but
like making posts on social media things
that are public forum where people can
find out about it right if you do more
of those things more people find out and
that would be the activity that's
associated with getting more customers
right but the thing is is that people
will know what that activity is right
they will know that inherently they
should be doing more of it and yet they
don't and so that is kind of the purpose
that i wanted to drill down in this
short video today is
why not and what is the way that we can
try and correct that or fix that i
wanted to give you the simplest
single hack that i have used
inadvertently and seen a tremendous
amount of success that is
asking myself the question what would a
person who does this type of thing do in
this instance the one that i'll tell you
that i've repeated a lot to myself over
the years probably over the last five or
ten years has been the repeated chorus
of
what would a wise man do i think it's
because i did not consider myself to be
very wise and i acted many ways
that were unwise um earlier on in my
life and i still continue to do so uh
but i try to do less of it right and i
think that and i'll borrow this again
from james clear's book your identity is
much more of a weighing system actually
this is not from this book but like it's
much more of a voting system where you
you cast votes in either direction based
on your activities of what type of
person you want to become and i think
the simplest distillation of that
concept is simply asking the question
what would this type of person do if you
can use that as the refrain that you
come back to over and over again the
chorus of your day that gets repeated
over and over again i think it's much
easier than trying to remember the
50-point checklist of all the activities
that you need to do to achieve the goal
in the the friend that came back in my
life um where we were having this
conversation i just distilled it down to
like what would a billionaire do
and so when we're confronted with these
crossroads right you wake up in the
morning and you're like i don't know
what i should start it's like what would
a billionaire do and so basically what
you can do is have a certain refrain or
chorus that you ask yourself what would
this type of person do and that type of
person when you ask that question is who
you will eventually become as you
continue to cast votes that reinforce
the stories that we tell ourselves about
who we are and those are the things that
create long-lasting deep change and
what's more about this is that these
changes when they become internal when
they become ingrained in our behavior
they become effortless but it takes time
and so i think that the mental cue that
i have given myself inadvertently over
the years i don't have a lot of choruses
that i refrain to or that i come back to
over and over again and so i tweeted
about one and it got shared a zillion
times but is what would someone 10 times
smarter than me do in this situation
right and a different way of saying that
is what would a billionaire do and and
word in whatever way that resonates with
you but i think rather than having that
big checklist you can put just a little
post-it on your computer or wherever you
work that's a reminder to yourself
that this is the type of person i want
to become
and in order to become this type of
person i need to do these things because
those actions will reinforce the
thoughts that i say about myself because
the whole concept behind affirmations
that i do not like right which is i am a
you know i'm a lion i'm a tiger i'm a
whatever right just saying them doesn't
make them true unless you're a crazy
person and most of us are not crazy i
think right there's plenty of crazy if
you don't get me wrong but if you're
probably watching this channel you're
probably at least semi-same right if we
have you know this degree of sanity
that's on our side then what we have to
do is create something else which is
evidence we have to give ourselves
evidence that we are this type of person
in order to become that but how do you
have evidence that you are going to be
this person when you have none well it
starts with activity it starts with
doing the stuff
and as an added correlator depending on
the goal that you have it might be what
would a person with a six pack do what
would a pro champion bodybuilder do what
would an amazing husband do or what
would the best husband in the world do
and so you can use this framework of
asking the question of what your ideal
self would do in any given circumstance
to apply to a vast number of scenarios
so rather than trying to fix for the
habit fixed for the being and then the
habits will take care of themselves in
accordance with the type of person that
you have stated you wish to become and
so then the goals we have become
becoming
the person we want to be once we know
who we want to become then that can
direct the types of activities that will
be in accordance with that and the
reason i like this better too is that if
we're trying to reinforce an identity or
an identity trait about ourselves this
is a really good habit i think that i've
picked up over the years but breaking
down the etymology of words
is really really cool and i think really
teaches us a lot about the words we say
and words matter a lot because they are
the things that encapsulate thoughts a
classic one which is like i didn't
really like the word philosopher because
i thought it sounded really fluffy when
i found out the etymology behind the
word which is filet which is to love her
to like and then sophos which is
knowledge or wisdom it's lover of wisdom
and i was like well shoot i am a lover
of wisdom and so now i actually have a
very positive association with the word
and to the same degree identity um comes
from like uh i don't remember the actual
latin word but entity is being right
like just beingness and it's in and of
itself and identical which is repeated
so repeated beingness is what your
identity is so what your actions what
you do literally becomes who you are
which means that we can actively change
who we are by changing what we do but it
is a reinforcing secular path of like i
am this type of person and therefore i
do these things and because they do
these types of things i am this type of
person right and so it's the chicken or
the egg but at some point we need to
take action in order to do that and so i
think the simple and easiest cue that we
can use to change who we are to change
character traits that we find
undesirable is to simply ask ourselves
when we're confronted with the decision
what would this type of person do
and then act in accordance to that and i
find it much simpler than having the
lists and having the the daily routines
and the things like that because if you
are this type of person
you will do the types of things that
that type of person would do and that
also comes down to the many decisions we
haven't accounted for yet you're going
to be confronted with situations that
you have not predicted in fact the vast
majority of us don't predict things well
in general it's because there's far more
variables than we can possibly
comprehend i think it's much more useful
for us to think about ourselves in terms
of if i were to encompass all of the
things that i would like to be right and
that's why i think the the what would
jesus do was such a powerful statement
in the christian community overall and
candidly people outside of the christian
community could use that same exact
thing which would jesus do in this
instance and probably get the right
activity and become more like jesus
right which is the entire goal of the
christian faith
and if it makes it easier for you to
think in a more
tangible sense when you're asking
yourself the question i think the reason
the jesus thing was so powerful is that
it's there's a very real identity that
they're associating this decision with
um the ones that i asked are what would
king solomon do
which he was considered you know one of
the richest and wisest men which is why
it's someone that i i revert back to and
the other person that i asked myself was
what would they do in this situation is
warren buffett and charlie munger when i
asked myself that question and it
depends on the scenario which person i'm
going to draw on to answer the question
depending on what suits best you know
what best suits the objective etc
but i think if you can if you can if you
don't know someone that you can make it
the value or the version of yourself
with that value or you can just use an
external person that embodies a lot of
the character traits that you hope to
have and that can be equally as
effective so it just depends on who you
are but i think any of those are good
strategies that you can employ
to maximally use this kind of tactic for
self-improvement and self-change what we
repeatedly choose to ask ourselves which
creates our identity which then creates
the tasks that we do in the activities
we spend our time on reinforces the
story that we tell ourselves about who
we are right or what type of person we
are what i shared with this individual i
said you know what do you want to become
and if it's like a billionaire it's like
cool then what would a billionaire do
and always asking ourselves that
question and the reason that this was
important when i was talking to this
individual i'll read you the text that i
had that i had said to him because they
got shared all over instagram when i
when i tweeted them or whatever is that
after you left i said here's a thought
for you so i was just like thinking
about the conversation we had and he had
felt kind of shitty and what's
interesting about this is like as you
level up in your life and this is just
an observation that i've had is that
like you will simply change who you
compare yourself to and i think jordan
peterson talks about this in some talk
he had but i find it very true which is
you just change who you compare yourself
to and so you always find a way to make
yourself feel terrible and even if
you're the best in the world and stuff
you'll just look at people who are
better at other things than you and
compare yourself to them to make
yourself feel bad this is what i said to
him and i'll share it with you i said
every winner and every loser have the
same goals what separates them are the
activities they commit to committing to
the activities that is the goal so
commit to the activities that is the
goal when you make a lot of money one
month you've achieved nothing because
the goal is the activities and then
later i said do me a favor instead of
writing down your goals just write down
what would a billionaire who lost it all
do or what would a billionaire do to
keep it simple or whatever version of
herself you want to be the doing and the
outcomes will happen as a result of the
main internal identity shift which you
can reinforce many times a day by asking
yourself that question at each crossroad
and so i i think that was uh relatively
you know i i think it's a good point to
end off on which is the only tactical
ask that i have for you is to simply
write down what type of person do i wish
to become and then make that the chorus
that you recite to yourself when you're
at your your crossroads when you're at
your decision points that are going to
create who you are on a repeated basis
every single day and i think going back
to that refrain will be all-encompassing
in terms of what would jesus do applies
to a zillion scenarios but everyone at
least in the christian faith and i use
it because it's a very simple catch-all
would want to become more christ-like
right and so whatever the christ version
is for you we can steal from that
concept and continually reinforce it by
asking ourselves those questions and if
you ask yourself the next joshua
question which is well alex i don't know
what a billionaire would do or i don't
know what an ifbb pro champ would do or
i don't know what uh okay well there's
two ways you can see this number one is
that most people know what they need to
do to lose weight but they don't
actually do it so i think that i could
push back on the vast majority of people
and say no you probably do know that and
i like this saying a lot which is we
need to be reminded more than we need to
be taught most people know they should
be doing more than they're currently
doing in order to achieve their goals
and i think an example of that is if
your if your family were kidnapped
you would probably act differently right
when you were trying to uh save them
because you would take significantly
more massive action in order to do so
right you would take huge action in
order to accomplish the goals which also
means that you're the type of person who
wants to save their family which is
actually kind of a total side note here
right but um
in in doing that you already knew what
to do all along you just weren't taking
the action now that's if that's the vast
majority of situations is covered with
that example but if you're in the
minority of situations right which is
like well i don't know how to become a
billionaire right well what are the
things that would lead you towards that
right which might be like maybe you need
to lower it a little bit which is what
would a millionaire do and if it's not
that then what would somebody who's
trying to become a millionaire
do and they would probably talk to
millionaires or whatever or talk to
people like the thing is is if you
really want the goal bad enough you can
ask the question in such a way that you
would be able to answer it and make
progress right and then the the nature
of the question itself can develop over
time as you discover what you believe
you need to do and i really will say
this again
the vast majority of us know what we
need to do we're just simply not doing
it and i think attacking why we're not
doing it is a much more fruitful
conversation than trying to discover the
the secrets of the universe because the
people who achieve the really
extraordinary things do the uncommonly
obvious thing for an inordinate period
of time and that is what separates them
is that they are doing it because it is
who they are rather than something to
achieve an outcome that is fine and
external that they don't have control
over because if you are doing it for who
you are you will continue to play the
game indefinitely which will give you
the outsize returns versus the person
who is doing it to make money which
means that when they do make money one
month they pull back on the gas because
they accomplish their objective of doing
the external thing rather than being who
they are or more of who they want to be
and so if you're new the channel by the
way welcome my name's alex like i said
earlier my wife and i own
acquisition.com it's a company that buys
minority interests in
uh service-based info coaching uh
digital products type businesses and
then helps them scale to like 30 50
million and beyond and that's what we do
full-time but i do this stuff uh just
because i struggled a lot on the way up
and i don't want other people to
struggle and i don't want my pain to be
in vain and so that is why i make these
videos so um welcome to moseynation lots
of love and i'll see you guys the next
video bye